hey this is presh tall walker a version
of this problem was used as an amazon
interview question a cable of 80 meters
is hanging from the top of two poles
that are both 50 meters from the ground
what is the distance between the two
poles to one decimal place if the center
of the cable is a 20 meters above the
ground and be 10 meters above the ground
now to be more specific a version of
problem B was asked during an Amazon
interview but I've included problem a
because it's interesting mathematically
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
[Music]
so let's solve the case of 20 meters
above the ground we have the ground we
have two poles of 50 meters each and we
have a hanging cable that's 80 meters
long the center of this cable is 20
meters from the ground and we want to
solve for the distance between the two
poles now I'll admit I had forgotten how
to solve this kind of problem so I had
to look up some formulas online many of
the websites referred to the physics
interpretation which involved weights
and tensions and I just wanted to get to
some of the mathematical formulas so I
found a great reference from Neil
Chatterjee and Bob Donita the hanging
cable problem for practical applications
in the Atlantic electronic journal of
mathematics I provided a link in the
video description and I recommend you
check it out so we'll solve this problem
using symmetry and a convenient
coordinate system first we'll split up
the cable into two lengths of 40 next
we'll consider only the distance from
the center of the cable to one of the
poles we can then double that distance
to get the distance between the two
poles we'll also use a convenient
coordinate system that's centered at the
center of this hanging cable in other
words the y axis goes at the center of
the cable and the x axis also goes so
that it's just touching and tangent to
the center of the cable so we want to
calculate this distance X from the paper
the general catenary equation that's
tangent to the ground or the x axis
takes the following form Y is equal to a
COS of the quantity x over a minus a
furthermore the top of the pole in this
diagram will be at the coordinate X
comma 30 so we can use the point at the
top of the pole
to get one equation this simplifies to
be a cosh of X over a is equal to 30
plus a it'll be convenient to divide
both sides by a so a the cosh of x over
a is equal to 30 plus a all
over a now we have another equation
which is using the length of half of the
cable this equation will be a times the
Cinch of x over a is equal to the length
of 40 meters
well again divide both sides by a to get
the Cinch of x over a is equal to 40
over a now we can use the hyperbolic
identity that the cosh squared of t
minus the Cinch squared of t is equal to
1 so we substitute in the values we've
just arrived and we can solve for this
value of a as a quadratic equation we
get that a is equal to 35 over 3 we now
figured out this unknown parameter and
we can then use it in our second
equation with cinch to solve for the
value of x and we end up that x is
approximately equal to 20 2.7 meters
which we will then double to get the
distance between the two poles as 45
point four meters amazing so now how do
we solve the next problem what if the
cable is only hanging 10 meters above
the ground now suppose you try and go
through the same exact method at this
point the top of the pole will be at a
point x comma 40 so we'll use the same
equations and we'll substitute in the
new values from this particular case now
when you substitute it into the
hyperbolic identity you get the
following equation and if you try to
solve it you run into a problem this
equation has no solution so what is
going on well we're gonna need to think
about this problem logically the hanging
cable is supposed to be 10 meters off
the ground which is 40 meters
from the top of the pole but half of the
cable is already 40 meters in other
words the cable must be folded exactly
in half and that means the two Poe
are coincident there are zero meters
apart so our diagram is actually going
to look like the following we don't
actually have a hanging cable between
two poles we actually have this cable is
going directly down from the two poles
because they are exactly at the same
spot
no equations required many employees can
mindlessly calculate the answer but how
many will think before they calculate
and to be honest I completely missed
this problem because I didn't see the
trick but I like to make videos about
these problems because it's like the old
saying goes fool me once shame on you
fool me twice you can't get fooled again
thanks for watching this video i post
math videos that can be watch for free
with topics from people around the world
because math is universal if you'd like
to help with the cause please subscribe
for free to get the newest videos watch
and share all of mind your decisions
videos so that more people can discover
the channel email me a math topic or
puzzle at presh at mind your decisions
comm check out my books which are linked
in the video description and if you want
to support that math is universal please
support financially on patreon thanks
for watching and thanks for your support